قالت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه ان احدى
وسبعين طائره تابعه للقوات الجويه الصينيه
منها مقاتلات وطائرات مسيره دخلت منطقه
تحديد الدفاع الجوي تايوانيه خلال الساعات
ال 24 الماضيه بعضها عبر خط الوسط لمضيق
تايوان في خطوه عقبه اعلان واشنطن عن
مساعدات ومبيعات عسكريه بقيمه 10 مليارات
دورا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مصارعه كيف نقرا ردود الفعل
الصينيه تجاه تايوان بعد اعلان بيجين
تنظيم تدريبات هجوميه ردا على ما وصفته
باستفزاز واشنطن لها عقب الموافقه على
تقديم اسلحه امريكيه لتايبي وهل من
مؤشراتنا على توجه صبيا نحو تصعيد اكبر
يتجاوز نطاق المناورات العسكريه الهجوميه
واختراقات منطقه الدفاع الجوي كيف استقبل
واشنطن الرسائل الى الصينيه وما هي ردود
الفعل المحتمله ازاء التحركات العسكريه
واي تاثيره لهذه التطورات على المشهدين
الاقليمي والدولي في ضوء تبادل اطراف
النزاع رسائل التصعيد وهل من فرص حقيقيه
وفعاله لخفض التوتر
[موسيقى]
لم تمهل الصين الصفقه العسكريه بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وتايوان حتى
بذرتها بتحركات عسكريه بلغت مستوى متقدما
من خلال توغل جوي وصفاته بالاكبر من نوعه
عكس في نظر مراقبين مقدار غضبي بيجين من
المستوى الذي وصل اليه التقاربه الامريكيه
تايواني فبعد ان تم تسجيل 146 جويا في
1969 في 2000 و 2021 بلغت تلك التوغلات
بحسب وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه
178 في مؤشر على تصاعدي توتر الاقليميا لم
تغيب عنه الرهانات الدوليه على نحو ينذر
بالمزيد مع تلويح الصين بين حنين واخر
بعمل عسكري لفرد الوحده مع تايوان وان
كانت تطرح في اغلب الوقت طريقا سلميا
للوصول الى تحقيق ذلك الحدث
اجنده قالتها الرئيسه تايوان سي انغوان
انها تؤكد يوما بعد يوم ضروره تعزيز
قدراتها الدفاعيه لمواجهه التوسع المستمر
للاستبداد حسب وصفها
في السنوات الاخيره اثر التوسع المستمر
للاستبداد على النظام الدولي والسلامه
والاستقرار ومع التغيرات في شكل الحرب
وتقدم تكنولوجيا الدفاع الوطني
التي يجريها الجيش الصيني هي الاكبر منذ
زياره رئيس المجلس النواب
رئيسيته مجلس النواب الامريكي نانسي
امريكيا صدرت تعليق عن مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جاء فيهم نشعر بقلق ايذاء النشاط
العسكريه الصينيه الاستفزازي قرب تايوان
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
بيتشرد وايت سهل الخبير في الشؤون الامنيه
في مؤسسه
نائب رئيس مركز الصيني والعولمه السيد جاو
سوف ابدا منك الى اي مدى يمكن ربط هذا
التصاعد في عمليات التغلغل
بالصفقه الامريكيه التايوانيه خاصه ان هذا
التوغل في مسار تصاعدي منذ 2020
شكرا على الاستضافه انت تثير نقطه وسوالنا
مهما ان العلاقه في حول جانبي ماضي تايوان
بامكان ان تحل عن طريق الطرق السلميه في
ذلك السياق فان اي محاوله لتسليح تايوان و
لتهيئه تايوان الى الحرب هي مصيرها الفشل
الامر لن يكون بناء على الاطلاق
باي طريقه من الطرق الامر لن يحل ويخدم
مصالح الشعب التايواني لسخريه القدر الامر
صالح
والسياسيه
القوى في واشنطن التي تريد ان تستخدمه
تايوان
ورقم من اجل منافستها السياسيه في ذلك
السياق هذا هذه محاوله مره اخرى لانهم لم
يقدروا حتى تقدير حكمه ورؤيه وشجاعت الناس
على جانبي المضيق والذين يريدون ان يحققوا
الوحده عن طريق طرق السلميه بالتالي لدينا
لا يجب ان اركز على الامور المهمه الصين
لديها حق شرعي كامل في الدفاع عن نفسها ضد
ان يتدخل اجنبيه في اي موقفا يتضمن تايوان
وهي تعترف بشكل كامل وبشائر عالميا ان
هناك صين واحده وتايوان هي جزء منها هذه
الصين بالتالي لا اعتقد ان واشطا بامكانها
ان تقوم باي شيء من ان تغير هذه الحقيقه
المعترف بها عالميا وهي الاساس على الوضع
الجيو سياسي الحالي وهذا الوضع الذي
يتضمنه تايوان وفي الاوقات الاخيره هذه
الامور قد تعود الى الاستسلام غير المشروط
في نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه بالتالي
اي احد يريد ان ينكر ان تايوان هي جزء من
الصين في حقيقه الامر هو يدمر الاسس التي
تم بناء عليها الوضع الدولي حاليا
رد الفعل الصيني هذا متوقعا عندما كانت
الولايات المتحده تقدم صفقه عسكريه
لتايوان بعشره مليارات دولار وكيف يمكن ان
تتعامل معهم
الامور
الناس في واشنطن بان الحكومه الصينيه قررت
بالفعل ان تترك بابا اعاده
قصر
ثابت
من انشطتها العسكريه
طائرات
النظري عن القرارات المحدده
تطرق اليها السيد جاو قال ان
اطرفان يريدان التوحيد على ضفتي
المضيق وفقا لاستطاعت الراي فان الشعب
التايواني يريد الانفصال او يريد ان يبقى
منفصلا عن جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه حاليا
ربما في المستقبل سوف يغيرون من
هذا التوجه هو سيتوحده ولكن الان يريدون
ان يبقوا منفصلين سيد فيكتور الموقف
الصيني كان يتراوح بين ايجاد مسار سلمي
والتلويح بعمل عسكري هل من مصلحه الصين
بالفعل ان تتجه الان الى هذا المربع
العسكري الخطير وجر الامور اليه
بدايه الصين تريد ان تحقق الوحده الوطنيه
عن طريق عن طريق السلميه ليس ذلك اي شك
حول هذا الامر وثانيا ان الصين لم
تستثني ابدا عن الطرق السلميه من اجل
تحقيق الوحده الوطنيه وخاصه عندما كان
الانفصاليون في تايوان ارادوا ان يدفعوا
بالامور الى نقطه الا عوده وهنالك ايضا في
حقيقه الامر قوات اجنبيه
في في تايوان اعتقد في نهايه المطاف ان
الشعب في طرفي جانبي الماضيه سيدركون انه
هنالك طريقه واحده لحل قضيه تايوان وهي عن
طريق المفاوضات عن طريق المفاوضات بطرق
سلميه وعن طريق الحديث عن الحل ومنع قوه
اجنبيه من فمها الولايات المتحده من
استخدام تايوان كارا ورقه ورقه من اجل
خدمه مصالحها جيل في العالم بالتالي
اعتقدوا ان الولايات المتحده ستفشل فشلا
ذريعا لانني اسمح لي ان اركز على نقطه
مهمه من ان من المصلحه الشعب الامريكي ان
يتفادى اي مواجهه عسكريه مع الصين اي احد
في واشنطن يريد ان يستفز مواجهه عسكريه
ويواجهونه لان هذا الامر سيدفع بالامور
الى نهايه العالم
ليس ضد مصالح الشعب الصيني فقط هو
بالتاكيد ضد المصالح الاساسيه للشعب
الامريكي ضد ايضا مصالح العالم باجمعها
بالتالي
واستخدمه الحكمه وهمم
السلام عليكم انتظروا الى النتيجه
النهائيه الولايات المتحده لا يمكنها ان
تغير من وضع تايوان بانها جزء من الصين
وبعض التوحيد
التايوان ستظل منفصله لانها ستظل تحت سلطه
قوانينها وسلطه نظامها السياسي لكنها جزء
من الصين
لن يدعونا لن تتفلسف في شرح الامور
في القراءه الامريكيه ما يشير الى ان
الصين سوف تذهب الى ابعد مما ذهبت اليه
فيكتوريا
الحكومه الصينيه ترغب
باعاده التوحيد بدون استخدام القوه
العسكريه وسيد بوتين يريد ذلك
وكوريا الشماليه تريد كوريا الجنوبيه
واعاده الوحده من دون حرب كما يريد بوتن
ايضا ولكن هذا غيره مرجح
في امريكا ربما بعد خمس سنوات او خمس عشره
سنه الحكومه الصينيه سوف تقرر من الطرف
البري ان تستخدمه القوه لتصل الى اعاده
التوحيد وهذا ما تساعده الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان تحول دونهم من خلال هذه
الصفقات الاسلحه وثمه ربما خطا قطور في
اوكرانيا امريكا
عشان تدفق الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا
وبالتالي اذا ما تحدثنا عن تايوان فان
امريكا توفر لها الاسلحه التي تعذب من
دفاعاتها وهذا سوف يفضي الى الحيل التي
دون
اعادته التوحيد بين الصين جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه وتايوان
[موسيقى]
ما الذي تتوقعه
الصين من الولايات المتحده
ما الذي يمكن ان يقدمانه عليه في هذا
الاتجاه
بدايه اسمح لي ان اسجل هذه النقطه اذا في
نهايه المطاف كان هنالك حرب نشبت بين
جانبي المضيق ذلك لان الولايات المتحده
بدات استمرت
وخرق الاعلانات 3 بين الصين والولايات
المتحده اذا في نهايه المطاف تاريخ سيلوم
الولايات المتحده على انها متواضعه في شان
هذه الحرب
هذه نقطه مهمه للغايه لا تصدق ان توفير
السلاح لتايوان لن يكون له اي عواقب في
نهايه المطاف دعني اسجل هذه النقطه معظم
الاسلحه التي قدمتها الولايات المتحده
لتايوان هي في نهايه المطاف ستنتهي همم في
المتحف العسكري في تايوان اه وربما في ارض
الصين
لن يكون هنالك اي قوه اي قوه على بامكانها
ان تجعل تايوان الدوله مستقله ذات سياده
بالتالي فان واشنطن تقوم بشيء ليس له اي
نتيجه هم لا يعرفوا انهم لا يمكنهم ان
يغيروا الوضع الحالي على جانبي مضيق
تايوان هم يعرفون انه عليهم ان يلتزموا
بهذا المبدا مبدا الصين الموحده وان
التايوان هي جزء من هذه الصين الموحده
بالتالي
واشنطينه تقوموا
باخذ هذا السبيل غير الشرعي والشرير
والشيطاني اريد ان اشرح هذا الامر واسجله
واسجله التاريخ
السيد رشد وايتس ما هي الاوراق
الموجوده لدى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وتايوان ويمكن ان تستخدم
[موسيقى]
قد تحدثت عن صفقات السلاح الوالده المتحده
الامريكيه تريده ان تعزها من قدرته تايوان
للدفاعي عن نفسها من خلال توفير السلاح
والتدريب
والتشجيع
وايضا التثقيف همم او التربيه العسكريه
كما تفعلوا مع اوكرانيا اوكرانيين ولكن
هذا ليس جزءا فقط
[موسيقى]
الاستراليون واليابانيون والهنود ودول
اسيا
الدول جنوب شرق اسيا وايضا التواصل من
خلال هذه الدول مع تايوان وارساله رسائل
الى الصين مفادوا ان هنالك عواقب اذا ما
استخدمت الصين العسكريه ربما فرض عقوبات
التي فرضت على روسيا والاقتصاد العالمي
سوف يتدعى مقارنه مع ما يجري في روسيا
واوكرانيا والاداره الامريكيه تريد ان
تتحدث مباشره مع الحكومه
الصينيه لنزع الفتيلي التوتر وتطرق ابوابا
اخرى وتحول دون المواجهه والعواقب الوخيمه
التي تحدث عنها السيد فيكتور وتحدث عنها
اخرين وهذا فعلا
هناك التزام من الولايات المتحده بعدم
التوجه الى الخيارات العسكريه وكذلك
تقريبا الالتزام الصيني ما يحدث الان لا
يعني ان همم الصين ستفقد مكاسبها مع
واشنطن
انجازها بهذا الوصف
بدايه دعني اذكره المشاهدين ان قائد
السابق لتايوان قال منذ بدايه
الستينيات ان الصين الاساسيه تمتلك
الاساسيه تمتلك امكانيات عسكريه كافيه لضم
تايوان بالقوه من اجل تحقيق الوحده
الوطنيه
من اجل تحقيق التوحيد وطرق سلميه لاننا
نريد السلام نريد ان يكون هنالك تعاون
وفاء ذلك
اذا كان الصراعات الولايات المتحده ان
تقوم باي شيء مفيد ونافع للبلديه تكون عن
طريق دعم السلام
والتفاهم بين طرفي الماضي لكن بدلا من
اضافه الوقود الى النار لانه في نهايه
المطاف اذا في نهايه التوحيد السلمي فان
الولايات المتحده تقوم بكل ما بوسعها من
اجل تحقيقه هذا التوحيد السلمي بين طرفي
المضيق التايواني وسيتم
لونها واحتقارها من قبل الشعب الصيني
لانهم لا ان الولايات المتحده لا تدافع عن
تحقيق السلام والاستقرار هي الولايات
المتحده تريد ان تقسمه
الناس والشعبين بين طرفين المضيق وتريد ان
تشعل الحرب هذا لن يكون له انعكاسات جيده
على الولايات المتحده ولالاف السنوات
القادمه
الى ان الولايات المتحده تريد ان تضغط على
الصين باعتبارها خطر الاستراتيجي الاكبر
كما ترى واشنطن من خلال الموقع على الحدود
السوريه
نعم هذا تعقيب مهم للغايه نعم رغم
المشاكل الطازجه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مع روسيا وكوريا الشماليه
والصين وفقا للوزير البلنكن الصين سوف
تكون البلد الوحيد الذي سيتمتعه بقدرات
ورغبه في تحدي القياده الامريكيه في
العالم لانهم يريدون اعاده صياغه النظام
العالمي بطرق مختلفه وتايوان هي بيضه
القبائل هناك
ديمقراطيه
وبخلاف جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه فان تايوان
هي تمد الجيش
الامريكي بالرقاقات وايضا هي سد ضد التوسع
الصيني اذا تعرضت الصين ان تسترد تايوان
فان اليابانيون سوف يشعرون بالتهديد
وربما سوف يجهزون انفسهم للقتال في خندق
واحد مع الامريكيين ضد الصينيين وبالتالي
هنالك قلق بشان التحدي الذي تمثله الصين
وهذا ما يجعل قضيه تايوان مهمه للغايه من
وجهه نظري اليابان الامريكيه ودول اخرى كل
هذه المؤشرات المجتمعه هل تشير الى تصاعد
وتوتر اكبر ام تعتقد سيد وايت ان هناك
فرصا للتهدئه
اسبانيا
الصعيد خلال سنوات القريه الماضيه سينما
خلال هذه السنه ولا يروح في الافق اي شيء
يغيره من المشهد المستقبلي اعني بذلك
التوسع في انشطه الصين العسكريه حول
تايوان واستمرار وصفقات السلاح الامريكيه
اجماع في الولايات المتحده
سواء لحمايه التايوان والصين هي التحدي
الاساسي ولا ارى قائد في الصين سوف يغير
من موقع الامريكيه واعتقد ان هذه مشكله
طويله لسنوات قادمه او لعقود قادمه سيما
فما يخص اداره هذه العلاقه بين الدولتين
قويتين تركزانه على تايوان كسبب محتمل
للحرب
شكرا جزيلا لكم من واشنطن بيتشرد وايدز
الخبير في الشؤون الامنيه في مؤسسه ويكي
ستراد ومن نيويورك فيكتور جاو نائب رئيس
مركز الصين والعوده
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
[موسيقى]